recently I renewed my daughter's
passport I had to go to the police
office three times wait 4 hours in Lan
cues pay cash to the post office and
fill out tons of forms of repetitive
data and why why did I waste so many
hours of my life when just a few years
ago I went to renew my own passport but
since I need it immediately for business
reasons they propos me the magic
solution the fast track once I
demonstrated the urgency and pay the
extra miracle I got my passport in 5
minutes whenever I see a fast track I
know there is a slow process and the
slow process often means a lot of wasted
time but what is the impact of all this
waste with simple calculations if every
single person would waste one of their
200 working days to renew the passport
every 5 years that's 0.1% of GDP in a
country like Italy this is 2 billion
euros of missed GDP and that's only for
passport now imagine the impact of the
waste from ID and license request work
permit tax declarations that's a several
points of GD P solving this problem of
waste would have a greater impact of
what law makers achieve through a
typical Financial act for the last 25
years I've analyzed how companies create
value for their customers and my
research shows that on average only 5%
of Labor really create value five
5% can you imagine most of our time is
wasted 5 minutes to issue a passport is
enough companies must analyze their
value streams which is the sequence of
activity to create value for their
customers and dig inside of each tiny
activity questioning its purpose which
activity really matters and what is just
a legacy are you wasting your labor by
over controlling executing redundant
tasks or fixing issues by rethinking the
true purpose of each task you will
discover what is waste and what is the
real gold of your company the creation
of value here is an example what is the
difference between a bunch of years of
corn 200 gam of flour and a pizza
organically not much but they have
different value labor and no how can
transform 20 cents of corn into €2 of
flour and then into a 20
Pizza we act like the economy is this
big complicated thing but income
dividends the stock of the private
Equity who owns the pizzeria their
Futures forward swap long and short
options their cost of capital even the
interest rate of the central banks they
are all derivatives of the real
gold which is the human labor which
transformed cheaper corn into expensive
pizza without that human labor none of
it exist and when you add up all the
value created by the people in a country
that's the GDP and productive labor has
no real impact on GDP so so here is the
exciting part if 5% of the labor
generates today the entire GDP imagine
if we could increase it just to
10% 10% of your work day is what 45
minutes with these 45 minutes we could
double the GDP the challenge is first to
discover this real gold because it is
hidden in a ocean of West wed labor
where do we look first well one of the
best places to find West is in company's
processes because they usually reflect
your company's past more than its
present or
future these legacies are massive waste
generators accountant matching purchase
orders with invoices is a legacy of
offline
transactions
submitting your time sheet online is a
legacy of punching into work with a
physical stamp my bank keeps sending me
account balances as a PDF so not only I
waste my time by logging in downloading
opening the PDF but searching a specific
transactions is as difficult as it was
40 years ago on paper instead of
carrying these legacies into the future
we should take a step
back when company analyze each and every
activity of their value streams they
should ask why am I doing this is it
still necessary can I use today's
technology to make it more efficiently
another consequence of this Legacy is
that we spend a large portion of our
life by filling out the same useless
data over and over again
to buy a plane ticket online some
airline companies require name family
name date of birth ID number expiration
date country gender with the distinction
Miss and misses for what so someone with
my same name cannot use my ticket so my
wife can't give her boarding pass to
another lady with her same name born on
her same date but still unmarried so
miss and non misses and today you
shouldn't need the gender in the
passport or a ticket this is a legacy of
a time where men and women didn't have
the same rights so take a closer look at
the data you collect for each piece of
information consider is it really
necessary and do we already have it I
remember one company's database showing
that 30% of their customer customers
were Afghan
accountant what are the odds of that why
so many accountant from
Afghanistan obviously the first job
listed alphabetically in the drop down
menu was accountant and the first
country was Afghanistan but what this
tells me is that the company didn't need
this information and the customer didn't
want to spend time feeling it another
likely source of waste is Over Control
ship I worked with a company whose
procurement process required 23 control
checkpoints now how many of these 23
people were looking closely do you think
and is it more likely that none of them
were paying careful attention assuming
that at least one of the other 22 were
too often over controllership kills
controllership because it kills
accountability
I was listening to a legal department
complain that in addition to checking
every contract for compliance they were
fixing grammar and spelling because
people drafting the contract knew that
lawyer would fix it but come on a lawyer
to check spelling that's expensive isn't
it instead we should ask ourself is that
control check really necessary
the answer is quite simple just math
does it cost more to do the check or to
fix the mistake if it occurs this gets
tricky with a very low probability very
high cost of failure event people tend
to over
mitigate and in many cases this creates
even more problems in UK all commercial
fire alarm systems must be tested weekly
and you often see inside the building
signs like uh fire test every Tuesday at
p.m. now if you were a criminal at what
time and which day would you commit your
crime without worrying too much about
alarms over mitigation creates also a
lot of waste first because of false
positives like a credit check
continuously blocking orders with no
real risk on
payment second because of pure over
processing my cinema app requires I
change my passport every 3 months six to
eight letters upper case lower case
special signs numbers whenever I need to
use it I spend 10 minutes to log in but
this is to avoid what that a hacker go
to the cinema at my place if they go I
hope they enjoy the movie because the
real risk to the cinema company is that
I buy few tickets logging in was so
inconvenient that I stopped using the
app companies should not sacrifice their
customer Journey for the sake of over
risk mitigation and by the way making
something difficult for your customers
it does not mean he'll be difficult for
a professional hacker more likely he'll
mean Less sales and less value created
alt together these small changes to your
company's processes can have a profound
effect entrepreneurs and managers should
refocus their priority into the real
gold attract Talent help them growth
Channel their energy into the real value
creation but there is another reason
arguably more important a world with
less waste and more time dedicated to
True Value creation is a more
sustainable world where people can enjoy
their work more free from time wasting
frustration and destraction they would
have more time with their family and
friends they would enjoy more art more
entertainment the real gold of our
economy is in your hands
please for a better word strive to
create more
value thank
you